I'm Sarah this is my husband Dustin I'm
Bart Belloc and this is my wife Felicia
Pilar hi I'm Judy my name is Ross my
name is Will and this is my wife Kelly
my name is Cynthia Stephens I'm David so
my name is Michelle what else did you
want me to tell you we both had student
loans both had credit cards seventy-five
thousand dollars in student loans we had
pretty considerable amount of debt when
I started the Dave Ramsey program
actually had just purchased a car I was
really starting to steps back I was
putting quote successful so I was
supposed to be living the dream so I
acquired more debt and more debt and
more debt and everything was pretty much
normal and so far as normal Americans
and what their finances look like you're
trying to impress people that you don't
even know and that's not you first you
know real turning point we'd see people
and they're going on a cruise or
vacation somewhere if we wanted to do
those things we were gonna have to
seriously make some some changes a light
bulb just immediately came on cuz I'm
like I don't have it together this is a
mess I couldn't fill my car with gas one
month because we had less than a hundred
dollars in the bank that feeling at the
pump I was like I will never ever be in
this again I would hear these families
making less money than I made alone why
is this so hard for me if it's so easy
for them they have four or five miles to
feet I did not want that weight on my
shoulders for the rest of my life
once I got like extremely frustrated and
went ahead I cut the cards that you know
I'd work you know in the evenings rather
than watching some television I worked
five overlapping jobs
it became than normal yeah I became
normal the last couple of months we were
able to just push it through and it just
felt like we were on top of the world
you would be blown out of the water what
you can do we were able to accomplish
these goals we set for ourselves that
never even could have dreamt was a
possibility I got my first tattoo it
means something to me I want to remind
myself that I paid off one hundred and
twenty thousand dollars and twenty seven
months one hundred eight thousand
dollars and thirty eight months fifty
eight thousand dollars forty million
dollars of negative net worth my mind is
completely changed we are completely
changed as a unit I'm free
I have nothing holding me back I'm not
afraid anymore and I look forward to the
future you know if I had had sat in the
chair the whole time I was never gonna
be able to build it up to the point
where I could walk and it's a exact same
thing with your debt you know if you
look at that number and get frustrated
from the beginning
you're never gonna start grab every
courage you have and go for it don't
look back no one said it was gonna be
easy just keep at it
life is not predictable certain things
are when you're in control of your money
someone recently asked me when we ever
get into debt again or something like
that nothing no never
it was just a small sacrifice for me to
be able to stick to the plan and do
better for myself and for my children
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]